i am in front of the city hall of barcelona
and there is the office of Mrs.
ada polao
the mayor of barcelona
yes,
that person who before being miraculous
was squash and denies to this day
that there is a real problem in barcelona
of
and who tells the rest of us that we are liars.
when we talk about it
47% of occupations in all of spain
are produced in catalonia
and specifically in the city of barcelona
more than 1,500 occupations per year
we Barcelonaers suffer
we have presented a battery of measures
to combat this
which today is present in our city.
that squatters are real housed in 24 hours
that cannot be registered in any city hall
that the owners of occupied housing
do not pay for supplies
in the face of problems solved
because we are sick of having a barcelona
of criminals
and above all
of misgovernment by the city council of barcelona
of Mrs.
ada colau and the socialist party
enough of destroying barcelona